so bill barr comes out and says the
following he says uh uh trump likes to
call anyone who disputes false election
fraud claims as a rhino
former u.s attorney general bill barr
was responding to a rant trump posted on
truth social in
which the former president said he had
no guts and was a weak and pathetic
rhino who was so afraid of being
impeached a rhino for him is anyone who
disagrees with him with the election was
stolen he rebuked he then recalled his
childhood
when he was he passed out
leaflets supporting barry goldwater the
arizona senator who was known as one of
the forefathers of the modern
conservative movement
as someone who handed out barry
goldwater literature when i was 14 years
old on the upper west side it's little
it's a little silly to say that what do
you think about what billboard is saying
to trump
look personally
in 2022 or 21 or 20 or 19
in this day and age it's unimaginable
and it's unacceptable to me personally
that quote unquote the legitimacy of any
election
by the casting of one invalid ballot
should ever happen meaning that if
someone is filling out a ballot
and is putting down information of a
person who's deceased or knowingly is
not here legally and not within their
legal right to vote and that vote is
counted to me personally that
makes the entire process illegitimate
yeah and whether it's the one vote to to
cause someone to win or lose or whether
or not it's just one vote that should
not have been counted is enough for me
as being an american living here in the
united states of america that should say
that we don't accept the election as is
and it needs to be redone and just by
virtue of you when you go to the airport
you have to show a passport a photo id
yeah facial recognition you know this
idea that i need to have an id to prove
who i am and that i am within my legal
right as an american to cast a vote and
this idea and again please hold the hate
mail please
that in some way that's racist
i just can't accept that everybody who
lives in the united states
should be fundamentally
uh wanting
that an election whether you agree with
it or not needs to be legitimized by
each and every vote that is cast that's
just my personal opinion and i'm sorry
and so i don't get into the weeds of
whether there was enough votes that were
illegitimate to have changed
the outcome
but i do know and by the way it's
indisputable that there was at least one
vote that was cast that was illegitimate
meaning that there were votes that were
cast that happened to be people that
were dead that to me illegitimizes the
entire process that's offensive to me
personally and that's offensive to me as
being an american but that's nothing new
this i mean there's always going to be
one but
here's what but here's if you're talking
160 million votes right the process the
whole election for one alleged vote we
live here in the united states of
america we are the richest
nation on this planet we are the most
sophisticated we listen people are going
to give their lives to come into this
community
into this country right we see what's
going on at the border what other
country in the world by the way what
other country on the planet are people
literally risking their lives to get
into
none
zero only the united states of america
so that should tell us as americans
that fundamentally we should ensure that
each and every vote that is casted is
legitimate and that person is legally
entitled and by the way
here's where it offends me the most
when you were born here in the united
states by virtue of being born here you
have citizenship you are an american
but i go back to and this is where i
find that we have gotten so far removed
my grandparents who immigrated from
russia and from germany and fled
they spilt their blood they gave their
blood their sweat and tears to come to
the united states to work
live lawfully contribute and provide
i think it's such a disrespect and such
a slap in anybody's face who has come
here legitimately and legally and who
has gone through the process and waited
the five the six the ten to twenty years
whatever it took for them to get and
obtain their citizenship
listen
someone that works for me just got their
citizenship i am telling you when
they speak of it you would think someone
died you would think something horrible
happened
the emotion of the gratitude of what
they
exube and the feeling of appreciation to
now saying
they are a citizen is unbelievable
but it's so recognizable because you see
the emotions coming out of these
questions and how disrespectful is it to
allow someone who's not here legitimacy
to be able to cast a vote and to then
skew the election and so my
my long-winded response is
yes
it should not be acceptable we do it
again
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here